who it was an emotional reunion for
Craig Morgan and Blake Shelton on a
Thursday episode of the Kelly Clarkson
show so Craig's new track the father my
son and the Holy Ghost is absolutely
heartbreaking it's about losing his
nine-year-old son in the tubing accident
which has made famous through Blake's
viral campaign before reuniting Craig
got candid but the emotional pain behind
the song I said up I don't know they
ever do it the guys worked it up we did
it on the Grand Ole Opry and I walked I
barely got through it and I walked off
and Ricky Scaggs was standing there and
I told Ricky I said he said that is a
beautiful song I said well I'm glad you
got to hear it because I'll never do it
again I said I'll never be able to do
that again and he put his hands on my
shoulders he said he said you have to
sing this song there are people that
need to hear this you have to do it and
so I mean I took it heart and here we
are but it was the unexpected appearance
from his good friend that the audience
and Craig weren't anticipating I won't
get surprised you still have someone
here to see you
[Applause]
now you might remember back in September
Blake starting the chain of tweets
encouraging fans to download Craig's new
single and bring it to the top of the
iTunes charts he even considered
everyone to get it above his own hit
single God's country writing quote I
would gladly give up my spot on country
radio to get this song on the father my
son and the Holy Ghost continued to
climb the iTunes country and all's on
our charts and with the help of
Shelton's loyal fans and stars like
Ellen DeGeneres Gwen Stefani and Travis
Tritt it didn't take long for the song
to go from number 75 to number one
beating out Liz Loza truth hurts this
led to Craig re signing with his
original record label and the song
started playing on more than 20 radio
stations incredible now Blake himself /
relate to Craig's loss when he was just
14 years old that Blake lost his older
brother in a car accident and told kelly
clarkson about the immediate connection
when hearing the song for the first time
Craig's been a friend of mine for so
long and Gwen and I were actually at the
funeral yeah and I didn't connect it to
anything - all I could
it was his story and it and it hit me
that hard just knowing him it's a
horrible tragedy I can't even imagine
but man you know it's just such a great
great song whoo after the reunion Craig
delivered a touching performance of the
song for the live audience that safe to
say the tears were definitely flowing
in the mornings I wake up here said to
the kitchen
it's rot allows us some ambition go
outside about myself
I know how he gets through that song it
really is amazing he's able to sing that
song after such tragedy after his
powerful performance it's back to flying
up the iTunes all genre chart and trails
just one spot behind Danny J's and
Justin Bieber's number one hit 10,000
hours on the country chart so the
Blake's surprise appearance and Craig's
performance have you reaching for the
tissues like all of us and Kelly
Clarkson's show let us know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to Canada's YouTube page
[Music]
you